راينا من بعيد رجلا يجري نحو سياج مزرعتنا
يطارده اناس كثيرون
قبل ان يقتل على يد مجموعه من الغواء ضحيه
اخرى لمرض تفشى في انحاء الهند
جريمته انه مسلم اما المرض فهو الكراهيه
قربي من وسط دلهي يقع معبد اللوتس بني هذا
المكان ليكون رمزا للتعايش بين كل الاديان
والطوائف في الهند لكن الترويجه لهذه
المثاليه الحالمه تفندها الاحياء المسلمه
القريبه من هنا
[موسيقى]
في طريقي لمقابله شاب مسلم كان على اتصال
مع والده لحظه مقتله
سلاح الساعه السابعه 57 دقيقه مساء تلقيت
مكالمه من والدي لكنه ظل صامتا وبقيت اردد
مرحبا مرحبا لكنه لم يرد عمل افتاب عالم
والد صابر سائق سياره اجره في دلهي لنحو
15 عاما في طريق عودته الى المنزل بسياره
الاجره اقل ثلاثه رجال اشاروا له من على
جانب الطريق ربما كانوا يشربون الخمر في
السياره وعرضوا على والدي ايضا لكنه رفض
سالوه عن سبب رفضه فاجابهم بانه لا يشرب
الكحوليات ارادوا معرفه السبب وسالوه عن
اسمه وعندما اخبرهم قالوا لك لهذا السبب
لا تشرب لانك مسلم تنامت مخاوف صابر عندما
طلب احد الرجال من والده ترديد عباره يعلن
فيها الولاء للديانه الهندوسيه
[موسيقى]
احد الاشخاص من والدي وقف السياره حتى
يتمكن من قضاء حاجته اوقف والد السياره
وسمعت الباب يفتح بعد ذلك لم اسمع شيئا
طلبت من فوري الى المكان مع جدي وعمي رايت
سياره والدي متوقفه على جانب الطريق وكانت
الشرطه وصلت قبل قالوا لي انه في المستشفى
وقد اصيب باصابات طفيفه في نحو الساعه
الواحده صباحا من تلك الليله اخذوني لرؤيه
والدي رايت جثته ملفوفه على نقاله لا
استطيع وصفه تلك اللحظه
ومني تسجيل افادتي كشاهد لكن الافاده كانت
مكتوبه بالفعل قالوا انها لا تبدو جريمه
كراهيه بل قضيه سطو وهم يحققون فيها
لكنني رايت محفظته في السياره لقد وثقنا
بان الشرطه ستؤدي عملها على اكمل وجه لكن
مر الان اكثر من عامين ولم يحدث شيء لم
يلقى القبض على احد ولم تساعدنا الدوله
ولا الحكومه المركزيه لم يبدا العنف ضد
الاقليات المسلمه في عهد حكومه كانت توجد
اعمال شغب لكن ما حدث بعد وصول حكومه مودي
الى السلطه كان عدم تدخل السلطه لوقف
الغواء
بقي المسلمون في ولايات شمال الهند واحده
تلو الاخرى موضع استهداف وغالبا ما اجبروا
على تمجيد رام وترديد هتاف جيش رييرام قبل
تعرضهم للضرب او القتل
قتل محمد جنيد بولايه هاريانا نفس الولايه
التي قتل فيها مسلمان حرقا في ديسمبر 2020
الى جرى تمييز الصبي كان من الواضح انه
مسلم صبي في السادسه عشر من عمره فوقوه
وطعنوه عده مرات تعرض لاكثر من اربعين
طعنه بينما استمر اخرون بضربه رغم اصابته
حتى توفي على متن القطار
قوانين حمايه الابقار ايضا يقولون مثلا
كانت مع فلان بقره وشككنا في انه لا يملك
الاذونات اللازمه فذهبنا لضربه ومات راينا
من بعيد رجلا يجري نحو سياج مزرعتنا
يطارده اناس كثيرون
وعندما وصل قريبا منا بدا الغوغاء ضربه
تدخلنا لنسال عن السبب الذي يضربونه من
اجله
انكم وهذا الرجل تذبحون البقر اخبرناهم ان
ذلك عار عن الصحه تماما وانه لا يوجد بقر
هنا ولا حتى ادوات ذبح
انتم مثله وحلفائه تذبحون البقر ثم
انهالوا علي بالضرب ايضا لقد تعرضنا للضرب
حتى فقدنا الوعي ثم بداوا سحبنا نحو
قريتهم
ثم نقلنا الى مستشفى جي اس خرج شخص من
سياره الجيب التي كان قاسم بداخلها واتجه
الى السياره التي كنت فيها ثم اخبرنا ان
قاسمه توفي
حليين
حيث لا الشرطه مع القضايا يجري تقديم ذلك
علنا للدعوه الى العنف والاغتصاب والاباده
الجماعيه
نحن بلد يؤمن بسياده القانون فالكل خاضع
هنا لحكم القانون كائنا من كان الشرطه
الهنديه نتاج التجربه الاستعماريه
وبالتالي فقد اعتادوا دائما تلبيه اوامر
الحكومه ايا كانت وهم غير مستقلين ويخضعون
بالكامل لسيطره الحكومه الحزب الحاكم
بالتاكيد لا يحب الاقليات وبفضل التوحد في
صفوف الاغلبيه فانه لا يحتاج حقا الى
اصوات الاقليات للفوز بالانتخابات ليس
لديهم حتى نائب مسلم واحد كجزء من الحزب
الحاكم يوجد عدد قليل جدا من المسلمين او
المسيحيين الذين هم في اي موقع قوه اليوم
لم يكن احدا بامانه كان المسلمون هم الهدف
الاول ولكن لم يكن احد في مامن من الهجوم
قد قتلت قبائل مسيحيه في كثير من الاحيان
حتى الطبقه العليا من الهندوس لم تسلم ذات
مره كانت تجمع الاسلامي الكبير اجتماع
الذي يقام في بولند شهر اتى اليمين
الهندوسي المتطرف وحاولوا تنفيذ بعض اعمال
العنف والشغب لكن الشرطه تتدخلت وبسبب
فشلهم بداوا مهاجمه الشرطه وقتلوا المفتش
سبوديسينج كان زوجي يخبر الناس المتجمعين
هناك بانه لن يسمح باي اضطراب في المنطقه
ولكن الى اي مدى يمكن لشخص واحد ان يصمد
امام 600 شخص امسكوا به من الخلف واطلقوا
النار عليه بمسدسه الخاص كواحد منهم
مفتش السينج الشرطه الى العمل ليتم القبض
على المشتبه بهم الرئيسيين لم يمر وقت
طويل حتى افرج عن المتهمين بكفاله بل
واحتفل انصارهم بعودتهم من جديد
يتهمون بقتل المفتش سينغ واولئك الذين
رحبوا بهم باكاليب الزهور ما هم الا اعضاء
في حركه اتخذ مؤسسوها من زعيم الفاشيه
الايطالي بينيتو موسوليني وادولف هتلر في
المانيا مصدر الهام لهم
الاتحاد الوطني الهندسي يو منظمه سريه
للغايه لا تحتفظ باي سجل عضويه اكبر نقابه
عماليه في البلاد بها
هي جناح منها اكبر حزب سياسي في البلاد
حزب بهارات يا جناتا هو كيان منها ايضا كل
ما تفعله حكومتنا يتوافق تماما مع ما
تريده منظمه ار اس اس في ولا التي يديرها
الحزب الحاكم تم تقديم قانون جديد
للمواطنه الذي قد يؤدي الى طرد مئات الاف
المسلمين من الهند ليس لدينا اي مكان نذهب
اليه نحن هنود حتى لو ذهبنا الى مكان اخر
فهل تقبلنا اي دوله لا هذا لا يحدث مع
الهندوس المسلمون فقط من يعتقلون الاجنده
كما تراه اجنده بسيطه المسلمون يجب ان
يرحلوا هناك سبعه مراكز اعتقال نشطه في
ولايه اسام تحتجز عددا غير معروف من
المسلمين ما يعرف حتى الان هو ان واحدا
وثلاثين على الاقل لقوا حتفهم خلف القضبان
توجهنا الى مدينه كارجون فتشتهر المدينه
بهدم منازل المسلمين وشركاتهم
ما يحدث في فلسطين يحدث هنا يشغلون
الجرافات للاشتباه بهذا الشخص
وبالتاكيد دون اي قرار محكمه
فقط لانني مسلم لا توجد قضيه ضدي عندما
جاؤوا لطخ الجدران بلوث البقر اولا وقفت
امام البوابه اطلب منهم عدم هدم المنزل
سالتهم اين اذهب زوجي متوفن اين اذهب
باطفالي لم يرحمونا ولم يسمحوا لنا حتى
باخذ اغراضنا لقد اردت ان اموت هناك ولم
اعد ارغب في العيش ولا اعرف الى اين اذهب
الان اريد ان اموت اذا كنتم تعيشون جميعا
في هذا البلد
تعيشوا معا بحب ما الذي يجلبهم سفك الدماء